how's it going brahs - baby how's it
going stream my name is P today we're
gonna play choice chamber as you can see
here there's a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
messages keep popping up and that's you
bros in and we'll in real life so you
can say a bunch of different things hi
hey sup yo all the high greetings and
it's all linked to twitch stream amazing
basically I will be playing and while I
play you brothers will be making guess
what sure it is so what kind of choices
basically what weapon will I get will
you bros be nice to me give me a good
weapon or will you be [ __ ] most
likely if I know you bros it well enough
you'll give me a shitty weapon or like a
shitty boost I remember last time I got
like this thing that when I could not
stop jumping and it was the worst so how
about that weapon press what would you
give me even will get me a sword a bow
or a hammer while I play with this ball
all right what are we getting what do we
want press I feel like it doesn't matter
how about a boat give me a boat I don't
get a ball I'm gonna be pissed
you'll be well pissed I'm gonna
unsubscribe from your bridge it's time
to find out what you bros voted for
alright so this is the first chest
I got a sub gizmo the [ __ ] is that only
universe Hickey can control say attack
shield ground collect switch it okay I
guess you bros control that [ __ ] you
gave me a hammer brush I asked for a bow
god dammit why do you never listen so
here he goes face 1 rock nailed it
give me another one hey the hammer is
pretty good oh god oh god
I took damage who's controlling those
alright
this is it next vote bros it can I jump
higher or double or Pogo please for the
love of God do not give me Pogo again I
got that last time it's the worst if I
see anyone vote Pogo I will unsubscribe
get rekt [ __ ]
I got stuck okay and then oh my god
there's so many ah what are you doing
nearly everyone they didn't shout it
shake Pogo you think I can't see that
it alright if you pit road pick me you
will be room [ __ ] sake oh my god oh so
so so those flying things are just
randomly selected you bros that's
awesome
okay I'm playing games with my brows let
me go de Fein let me go
I got we got another something gizmo
this time just sure would live alright
[ __ ] this it's hard lift me up lift me
up you need to lift me to the other side
press help oh [ __ ] you're lifting me up
holy [ __ ] that's awesome ah lift me up
lift me up bro bro bro bro bro
alright random I got random uh lift lift
me up lift me up high Alabama what no I
asked your browser left mag [ __ ] okay ah
yes take me to the other side
oh Jesus Christ
now let's not give me a [ __ ] pogo
jump I told you many times don't get by
the pogo jump Jesus Christ
hey the bow
thanks Bruce give me crits that'd be
awesome hip hip appeal ah oh hello
really how am I supposed to attack them
with a [ __ ] Pogo job
okay okay they're on fire now thanks for
lifting me up mr. Darth you're my main
[ __ ] mr. dart I love you alright
alright I like my enemies like I like my
women
husky oh my god is so intense if only I
hadn't had this stupid pogo jump ah
oh god don't drop me there don't drop in
the lava please I don't ask for a lot
just not to be dropped in lava please
double jump
I have double jump Thanks brush you're
the best
yay oh so easy now you can just do this
oh my god serious serious serious Siri
what is going on oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god yeah amazing
Wow just fantastic
Oh oh my god
this game is ridiculous it's almost like
we're collaborating all right like if
you enjoyed this video brooch hit
subscribe to become bro today up
anything left to say in the shot dick
great